des bisous aucune formation les caves
ecoiffier je pense avoir aussi donné des
informations erronées bras sordide
lubrizol canicule chèque énergie
poursuit violences faites aux femmes de
karité étudiants punaises de lit cheveau
mutilé kobe 19 mais aussi patron en
détresse autour de numéros gratuits
qu'il existe de mauvais et ce n'est pas
fini
le 4 décembre emmanuel marco a été
interrogé pendant plus de 12 heures par
le média en ligne brut au cours de cette
interview il annonce la création d'un
numéro d'appel soit un numéro vert afin
de dénoncer les contrôles de police au
faciès sur les contrôles c'est qu'on va
mettre en place une plateforme nationale
avec un numéro d'appel la possibilité de
signaler
très rapidement le chef de l'état est
vivement critiqué par l'opposition
c'est le cas de jean luc mélenchon ou de
jordan bardella la politique du numéro
vert sur le moyen utilisé le numéro vert
un mois plus tard c'est olivier ferrand
qui annonce la mise en place d'un
nouveau numéro vert pour prendre rendez
vous afin de se faire vacciner contre le
coup vite 19 vous êtes nombreux à vous
interroger sur la multiplication de ces
plateformes afin de répondre à vos
interrogations pour facture on en qui tu
es et passer des dizaines d'appels alors
qui sont les personnes derrière ces
numéros verts comment les
téléconseillers sont ils recrutés et si
je vous disais que derrière l'un de ses
numéros verts se cache la sixième
fortune de france s'est en fait depuis
le début du monde à des mails même accro
que d'une dizaine de numéros verts ont
été lancés et par numéro vert en tournée
tout simplement numéro gratuit c'est
donc le cas de ce numéro la plateforme
d'appel consacré aux copies 19
vous l'avez entendu bonjour mais
détrompez vous ce n'est pas le ministère
de la santé qui réceptionne les appels
cela a d'ailleurs été assez vite révélé
puisque peut-on après la mise en place
du numéro verte
la plateforme a fait face à quelques
couacs certains français qui ont eu
recours se sont plaints d'un pur
d'attendre trop long mais aussi de
réponse hasardeuse et si cela vous
choque ce n'est pour autant à et tous
n'ont pas en effet derrière ces
plateformes plusieurs entreprises ont
été mobilisés dès le mois de février
c'est le cas de teleperformance et de
sites être l'une est leader mondial des
centres d'appels et l'autre et de
grimaces en compensant par la sixième
fortune de france la famille mulliez
et si ce nom ne vous évoque rien vous
connaissez forcément les marques qui lui
appartiennent aux chants des camions
lourds à berlin ou encore kiabi
bref un panel de marques qui n'a aucun
rapport avec les domaines de la santé et
ses deux entreprises n'exigeait leur
télé conseillers aucune formation en
santé et c'est justement ce que déplore
l'une d'entre elles c'est l'opération
qui a été un peu compliqué les appels et
différents les uns des joueurs de la
formation que j'ai eus n'a duré qu'une
demi journée en sachant qu'on a
simplement eu des documents on peut
retrouver directement sur le site du
gouvernement fallu plus de deux
formations que cela j'allais directement
sur le site du gouvernement la guerre
c'est moi qui cherchais et anciennement
fait tourner et qu'on appelle une
formation dans le médical
automatiquement on n'était pas moi je
sais que j'ai été déçu des réponses que
je donnais parce que je savais pas quoi
leur dire et certains moments je n'avais
pas du tout de réponse et je pense avoir
aussi donné des informations erronées
ca/sports possible comme je pense comme
tous vos petits ce qu'ils font sur le
l'opération avec moi le numéro de
téléphone est mis en place et chaque
jour à la télévision sur internet par la
pression ce numéro en fait on va
répondre à tous nos finales quand on a
des questions d'ordre médical ont donc
concrètement si vous avez déjà appeler
ce numéro la personne qui vous a répondu
non probablement eu aucune expérience
dans le domaine de la santé et la
formation reçue pour répondre à ses
appels aussi entre une demi journée et
trois jours en fonction des entreprises
mais face à ces critiques le
gouvernement se défend la création de ce
numéro vert il ya un an avait pour
objectif de désengorger les appels au
samu et se focaliser sur les questions
non médical expliquer la cause ou cas
pact renseigner sur un motif à cocher
sur l'attestation mais aussi rassurer
les apprenants entreprises quand elle a
vendu ce service à l'état c'était par
rapport à l' expertise 500 intérimaires
qui ont été recrutés pour la période
les premières personnes qui ont été
recrutés n'ont pas du tout été même
forme et qu'il fallait simplement savoir
répondre
c'est le de landorthe cdta on ne devait
qu'en tant que prestataire on doit
respecter
comment et dire exactement ce que
souhaitait le gouvernement ce qu'on
demandait aux conseillers en fait c'est
d'être d'avoir de l'empathie que l'
expertise de rassurer ce qu'on n'est pas
médecin ici les appels ont littéralement
explosé durant le premier confirmant
notamment pour des questions relatives
aux masques ou aux attestations
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui on
reçoit encore des appels un petit peu
moins qu'au tout début de la crise
sanitaire mais après c'est aussi
fluctuant par rapport à l'actualité
aujourd'hui on a une actualité qui est
très tourné vaccins et les stratégies de
vaccination donc là on commence à avoir
des volumes un peu plus important sur
cette typologie ce n'était pas le cas où
je dirais déjà le mois dernier 6 pour le
numéro vert consacré aux convives 19 ce
sont les entreprises privées qui ont été
mobilisés ce n'est pas le cas de tous
les numéros d'appel prenons l'exemple du
numéro d'appel pour les punaises de lit
mis en place en février 2020 cette
plateforme a été confiée à l'anil
l'agencé nationale d'information sur le
logement une association agréée par le
ministère du logement
et lorsque l'on appelle ce numéro on est
tout simplement dirigés vers l' agence
de notre département
autre élément quand on y regarde de plus
près ce nouveau numéro
mais d'autres que celui pour les
logements dits déjà mis en place
plusieurs mois auparavant mais vérifions
si c'est le cas pour tous ces numéros
verts et s'ils fonctionnent tous
réellement aujourd'hui
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue et reba
formation d'aidé d'urgence
du coup après avoir passé ses appels on
en tire deux conclusions premiers
éléments
toutes ces plates formes ne sont pas des
numéros verts il ya aussi des numéros 10
c'est à dire que la balle revient au
prix d'un appel local généralement
inclus dans les forfaits de téléphone
c'est le cas du numéro pour la précarité
étudiante et pour les punaises de lit
deuxième élément ces numéros sont bel et
bien en état de marche mais ce sont soit
des entreprises privées soient des
entreprises du service public qui
réceptionne les appels finalement ces
numéros verts et gris ne sont que des
outils permettant d'être envoyés vers
des plateformes déjà en place et leur
utilité semble limité
pourtant c'est plate forme d'appels ont
deux objectifs le premier obtenir des
informations et rassurer la population
en effet ces numéros verts permettent
d'une part d'apporter des réponses à des
questions et d'autre part permet de
recueillir des informations essentielles
de la part du public comme dans l'
enquête sur les chevaux mutilés mais
derrière cette utilité publique la mise
en place de ces numéros d'appel permet
au gouvernement de montrer sa réactivité
face à un problème donné
et c'est dans l'intérêt de l'état en
matière de communication politique
il s'agit du second objectif qui est un
outil qui a pour objectif de moderniser
l'image de l'état qui est une image
parfois et on l'a vu encore plus cours
de cette crise sanitaire d'une structure
qui apparaît pesant tu es plus réactive
le problème que cela pose c'est l'idée
que finalement n'étant pas forcément
capable de traiter dans le fond un
problème on le traîne en la forme le
sentiment qui peut éventuellement
ensuite se développer avec la
généralisation encore une fois de ses
numéros verts sz
finalement on met en place un processus
de communication mais que ce processus
de communication permet de gagner du
temps en face un problème que l'on n'est
pas forcément capable en temps et en
heure la multiplication de ces numéros
d'appel semble donc être une stratégie
de communication largement adoptées par
le gouvernement qui n'est pas sans
déplaire aux entreprises mobilisées
en effet la crise ducobu 19 a largement
profité à teleperformance l'entreprise
mobilisés pour le numéro vert a connu
une hausse nette de son chiffre
d'affaires et a pu faire son entrée au
cac 40
au mois de juin